the bears made their move on draft night
and the head coach of the chicago bears
kind enough to call back into this show
matt nagy how are you coach
hey rich how you doing i'm doing great
you are indeed you are indeed you've got
a new quarterback
in the fold um how how closely were you
monitoring
justin fields throughout this entire
process walk me through your
your evaluation of him and your decision
to say let's go get him
yeah no it was a uh it was a fun process
um
anytime you're evaluating all these guys
let alone the quarterback position and
you know those those five guys there in
the first round they're all so different
but but yet so uh many good qualities to
them and
um with justin it was just one of those
things where
the more tape you watch the more people
you talk to
the more you really realize the uh the
possibility that something could happen
you really started visualizing it and uh
you know ryan and i just kind of going
through
our evaluations and then my discussions
going back to last year with coach ryan
day
as we were talking through some of his
ohio state players and then we got to
justin
uh it's amazing how things happen and
why things happen and so to be able to
be in that draft room that day
be able to have somebody that will move
up let us move up to 11 with the giants
and
and get a talent like justin uh it was
certainly you know really exciting
well you know and obviously i i want to
put a pin in the
just in conversation for just a moment
um and go even further back in time
and and and i understand whenever i ask
a coach about something like this
it can be viewed and read as well justin
wasn't our first option
but it's understood that the first
option could potentially be russell
wilson that makes
complete sense uh how how close did you
did you guys ever come to your yolo
attempt at russell wilson at in north
dakota well i think that
the biggest thing for when when we go
into that
that part of our uh structure there
offensively is you know knowing the
direction we were going to go to with
the quarterback
and and russell being one of those that
that obviously not from our end but from
from that side uh popped up it was
something that we
we looked into and you know there it's
it's
uh all these guys you have to say to
yourself okay what's real and what's not
real and there's just so many things
that
that go into a decision like that and
they're big decisions but
ultimately in the end i think you know
rich like you know you have a
team in seattle who is obviously very uh
happy with him and wasn't going to do
anything with him and so for us
we definitely explored it but uh in the
end uh
you know obviously nothing came to
fruition so i guess um
then it's a waste of my time to ask you
if you kick the tires on trying to get
aaron rodgers
like uh yeah yeah
that would be a waste of your time
although you know we
we uh we certainly know what kind of
player he is and i do
last three years here but yeah that's uh
us definitely stay away from that no i
could see i guess a very very warm place
would have to freeze over many many
times for
that conversation probably a few times
i bet so so uh then comes the
conversation about
um you and justin fields and what plan
you see
for him right now yeah yeah so that that
that's
that's real and i think that's probably
the million dollar question for so many
people uh so many of our fans across the
country our city of chicago our
players coaches everybody and um as we
went into this that that that is one
thing that we got to be really really
clean with
we got to under i understand from the
front end from an outsider's perspective
hey
it's real simple this this kid you know
how do you not play him is he's so
talented he's got to play
week one he's got to be the starter week
one how do you not do that
well there's a lot of things that go
into that and for me i was fortunate
enough to be in a similar i'm not saying
the same
but similar situation with alex smith
and and patrick and the blueprint of
that
um of being able for me to be involved
in every one of those meetings
every one of those practices every one
of those travel days on the bus and
airplane to the hotel
every one of those sideline
conversations that we had
from week one until the end of the
regular season and into the playoffs
and two people that have different
avenues in alex and patrick
and different personalities but um
in the end it ended up working for both
of them and that's at least where we're
going to start we have a guy in andy
dalton that we have a lot of belief in
he's had a nine-year career and a lot of
he's seen a lot of different defenses
he's a he's a true pro and he's come in
here to be able to help us out as much
as he can
and i think when you bring justin into
the mix
there's so many different things that he
has to learn that go into being an nfl
quarterback and
you know he's sending us video clips of
just the simplicities of calling
a cadence at the line of scrimmage from
his bedroom
so we can hear the cadences and what it
sounds like with the voice inflection
he hasn't had to really do that in
college it's a knee lift or a clap of
the hands
and so everything that we all take for
granted that we think is simple
when you get to rookie mini camp for the
first time
and you're calling a cadence at the line
of scrimmage or you're calling to play
in a huddle which you really never had
to do
that's hard that's different and it
takes time and what that does is it
takes away from your strengths as a
football player
that we all see what you do and so
we got to make sure as a staff that we
take it step by step and don't rush it
if we rush it and we take this thing too
fast and he's not ready
it's going to be bad for the chicago
bears and it's going to be bad for
justin fields and in the end
this needs to be the best decision for
the chicago bears and for justin fields
so you're
you're making him take selfie videos in
his in his room going through the
cadence of plays
that are that are on that bu play sheet
yeah you hold it
so it's cool yeah yeah so he's sending
us uh
video clips of what his voice sounds
like and
like he's at the last scrimmage from his
bedroom and then coach flip our
quarterback coach passing game
coordinator is uh
having him do a bunch of flash cards and
drawing up every motion formation shift
that we have in the offense and
it's literally day one 101 so that he
can come in here and and step by step
learn how to play the quarterback
position
matt maggie head coach former coach of
the year i guess once you're coached
you're always coach of the year
of the chicago bears right here on the
rich eisen show so you know you
mentioned how
you you've been through uh the drafting
of a first round quarterback that you've
traded up to go get
and then sit him for the bulk of an
entire season with the exception of
the last game in patrick mahomes um
while alex smith took all the other
starts um
what what did mahomes learn did you
think
that you think could be translatable to
justin fields like literally we've all
seen what mahomes has become
what did what did he glean like what you
had a front row seat for that what do
you think he gleaned that you think
justin fields could glean
from sure i think number one is
understanding
what the tempo is like in practice so he
got to see how did
what was alex's routine every day how
did he start practice with his
his warm-ups with his his throws how did
he um
you know communicate with players in
between practice and series on offense
uh with things that they're doing right
or wrong or how how does he get extra
work after practice
how do you watch tape so we can all put
on the video and say hey yeah i just
watched the game of the san francisco
49ers versus the minnesota vikings but
what are you really watching is there
what kind of cut ups are you watching
how are you taking notes um what time
are you getting in in the morning and
why are you getting in that earlier that
late
how late are you staying what does your
are you investing in your body are you
lifting weights
monday tuesday wednesday thursday or is
it three days a week and or or two or
three days a week
um just uh listening i think the
greatest thing
that patrick did and this is in his dna
it's very natural for him
is he came in day one and he
came in and he listened he was an
observer and he listened to what alex
said
he watched him he he took notes and
there might have been some things that
he wanted to ask him but he waited for
the right time to do it in front of the
right people
and then inevitably over time by the end
of the week in that game that you just
mentioned that patrick got his first
start against the broncos in denver week
16.
by that end of this season alex was now
asking patrick questions about what he's
seeing with the opponent
opposing defense to me that was more
powerful than anything
they built trust in one another and they
did it the right way they took the egos
and they threw them out the door
patrick was willing to learn from alex
alex was willing to learn from patrick
and it was a win-win for the kansas city
chiefs
and that to me for patrick he'll always
look back i bet
and say it was a very very valuable and
important year
is that going to happen for us i don't
know you know but that's at least where
we're going to start well and i i think
it's a terrific start
coach but you know i'll shoot you
straight i always do that and i always
appreciate that you
you do the same you know can uh uh
kansas city's not chicago
uh alex smith had years of playoff
experience for the fan base built up
um andy dalton's coming in we all know
um andy's got some experience winning
championships
in the afc north but uh i i'm
i don't know if you're gonna have the
luxury that you're referring to
and i'm wondering if how how do you
prepare for that
that you want to hold off but um maybe
the circumstances
won't allow you to coach yeah so and
that's very very real and true and and
you know it is that's why i say it is
slightly different because alex did have
those four years
and playoff games with his own teammates
coaches and and city
that andy doesn't have you know andy
hasn't been with any of these players
yet
uh let alone any any one season so
that's where
we got to make sure meaning myself and
our coaching staff
that that um are the scenario
that plays out is right for justin
and the chicago bears and what i mean by
that is justin has to be
ready uh the worst thing that that would
that we could do
is put justin into a situation
where there's some you know where he
failed and and it's hard for him now is
there gonna be times where he fails
absolutely that's how you learn
but we will know if justin gives us a
better chance to win
than andy does then that's something
that
we and myself as the head coach who
makes the decision
we'll have to make that choice uh we
have a lot of belief with the roster
that we have and the players we have
that with andy
we can do a lot of good things um but we
also have to be real and and
i have to be prepared for what you just
brought up and as long as
we know that whoever that quarterback is
that they're better for the bears and if
that's justin
then we'll do that and no matter whether
it's whatever week it is
we will make sure that it's best
scenario for justin and best for the
bears
so then you're not the one who hit send
on the tweet that said andy dalton was
qb one
you're not that good
i feel bad you know because i also
called out the whoever was the
i'm sure it's a very conscientious
person who's the uh running your account
i got
i feel bad taking a shot the person you
know
might be in their 20s or something like
that but did somebody bring that to your
attention
did you get that well i just think you
know we we we go through
everything and you know our our uh
people in our whole organization you
know they
they work hard and they do everything
they can to help our team out and
um you know there there's an excitement
with andy and and you know this is
uh where we are and uh we're proud of
the guys we have and looking forward to
getting andy going they were just being
them right whoever hits
them there you go that's exactly right i
like it
they were just being them that's all
they want um
and what about you coach i mean you know
you're you're a very positive guy and
and that that that obviously serves
being a head coach in the nfl certainly
of the chicago bears
you know you're you're aware you know
this league to get another opportunity
to coach
uh a rookie or you obviously were
coaching trubisky in year two and that
did not work out as we all know despite
you winning coach of the year and your
first year with him
to get another crack at it is it's a
rarity in this league
do you ever sit around and take stock in
something like that
for your options no i do i i absolutely
do and i think that every day that i'm
in this position
and i've been you know uh very fortunate
to work for
uh the mccaskey family and and uh you
know this this organization and who we
have here
you know i i appreciate the opportunity
they've given me and
it's it's been uh you know coming in in
2018
and having the success we had as a team
and winning the nfc north and going to
the playoffs and
and then the following year we missed
the playoffs and uh
you know and and then you go back to the
playoffs this year but yet you know
you're through you go through a losing
streak that was difficult
but in the end you're you're surrounded
by good people
um that support you and i think that
starts at the very top
and that's what i'm thankful for and
there's a belief and there's a trust and
they have that in us we have that in
them and it's our job
as leaders you know is to make sure that
you stay positive and that everybody
understands
that this thing is alive there's an
excitement um
you know when you go through these
trials and tribulations and
you hit adversity um there's that fork
in the road and you can go different
ways
and this this city this organization um
our team
the last couple years has fought through
that adversity and now here we are
presented from for me selfishly with a
fourth year
to be able to to have another
opportunity and now with justin
um it's it's about developing he needs
to have a successful
entry into this league and i feel like i
was taught by one of the best coaches if
not the greatest coach in the history of
the nfl and coach andy reed
and he taught me how to be a head coach
and how to
you know handle situations and develop
quarterbacks like this and so
um we're all going to do it together i
got great coaches and ryan pace and i
doing this thing together and and so
that that's where we're at man and it's
uh
for us right now it's good times and we
we need to make the most of it and be
great coaches
no doubt you know i know you had a still
rest of the first round a monitor and
then the next two days of the draft to
monitor but when you hung up the phone
from justin fields and everything was
completed you
you had to just sit back and go okay
here we go like this is
what an opportunity what a major refresh
what a reset button that we just hit
um that had to be a good few minutes for
you and ryan pace
in that dream it was i imagine and you
know as you go into that draft when
everything happens
we went we congratulated all of our
coaches all of our personnel our scout
everybody and there was probably a good
hour or two that passed
but when the dust settled at night time
and and everything was done the draft is
over
uh you know walked into ryan's office
and he just uh
you we you know we gave each other just
a little fist bump
and and just uh you know post code here
but a little fist bump and just like you
know hey
there's so much stuff that goes into
that
that one night and you never know how
it's going to go
there's so many phone conversations
there's so many hours of watching tape
there's so many different opinions from
different people
and in the end you know you you end up
getting your guy in justin fields
and that's a good feeling and now like i
told ryan
you know we went and we got this guy and
now it's our job as a coaching staff to
develop him
and we need to do everything we can so
that he has a hell of a career
you know however that is and when we
look back we say we did it the right way
and it was best for the chicago bears
and justin fields and we'll see when
that is matt and aggie thank you for the
time as always always appreciate your
you're coming on this show uh always uh
enjoy our chats let's do it again down
the line have a good spring and summer
we'll chat
thanks rich you take care if you ever
need anything shout out i really
appreciate you saying that look for my
call that's matt negge
bears head coach 2018 nfl coach of the
year
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here